when I was working at Google and you
walk in the door and you get to see who
you're surrounded who your peers are
it's very apparent that that is like
there's a reason why their hiring
process is so long and so kind of a
little bit tedious but just it it's
quite the
complex several hurdles that you have to
get over before you actually get in the
door and I I understand why those
hurdles are so high now because once you
get in they give you kind of the keys to
the castle and say just go run make
mistakes mes learn and they trust you a
lot and so for me once we have you know
I know I have high quality talent to
work with it comes down to If This Were
to go completely sideways how big of
screw-up would it be publicly into our
community and if the answer is a six or
above I probably want to give it a
little bit more Hands-On attention and
if the answer is like an eight or above
then I want to be be heavily involved in
that process right mhm if it's a if it's
a kind of five or below who cares like
let them make them mistake and and go
because you just don't have time to look
at everything right not only that but
you don't want your employees and look I
think you're better at side yeah yeah
exactly exactly right it's like you
don't want them to feel like you're the
teacher looking over their shoulder to
like point out every mistake they make
as they're
working which has been hard for me to
learn honestly because I am such a
perfectionist I don't know if I told you
this did I tell you that I was diagnosed
with moderate severe OCD by a
psychiatrist did I tell you this oh holy
[__] that all makes sense now yeah yeah
exactly what was funny what was funny is
that I went through this long thing and
then the psychiatrist like okay I feel
like I have a very confident read on our
our current state of play and the
diagnosis and he so he tells me all
this and he says we're on zoom and he's
like I understand this could be a lot to
take in if you need time we can take a
break if you want to hop on the call and
pick up tomorrow and I was like are you
[__] kidding me I'm not surprised at
all yeah I'm like yeah okay fine like
what's next that's fine dude it's so
funny you say that I've got an awesome
new therapist that I'm really enjoying
she's amazing and she's like I want to
refer you to someone because I what
you're describing sounds like 88 and I'm
like yeah no [__]
like big surprise you know like shock
shocker yeah
shocker it literally happened a week ago
it's
amazing yeah yeah I reached out to a
couple of my ex-girlfriends who I'm
friendly with when I asked them I was
like does this like square with your
experience and they're like yeah yeah it
squares with my experience I was like
yeah okay confirmed and this was in just
to provide the context this was in the
context of trying to
determine
neuroanatomical targets for something
referred to as accelerated TMS which I'm
hoping to talk quite a bit more about
but I I don't feel comfortable yet
making any type of recommendation but it
is a a new protocol with a a very I
shouldn't say very old but like 1980s is
forward developing technology
transcranial magnetic
stimulation so it's it's brain
stimulation
for the purposes of
minimizing or eliminating the symptoms
of certain things like OCD
depression generalized or maybe it's
just general anxiety disorder I think
it's generalized anxiety disorder Gad
and I become very interested in this
because there are data related to
something that's been called the saint
protocol I think that had too many
religious overtones so they abbreviated
to I think maybe SNT it's a
Stanford based brain stimulation lab
there's some incredible scientists
involved including Nolan Williams who's
incredibly impressive to me who have
developed this protocol and the
magnitude of effect that I have seen in
some of the data this does not apply to
all people does not apply to all
conditions but shows a magnitude of
effect that makes it equally as
interesting to me as psychedelic
assisted therapy it's the only thing I
have come across in The Last 5 Years
that approaches the
amplitude of effect size that you see in
some of these results it's B it's
bananas but it's very intense by
accelerated TMS what that means is
you're getting your brain Zapped yeah
and it's not
technically whatever we don't have to
get into zapping it's using magnetism
but you [__] feel it let me let me
let me make it very clear you're getting
Zapped
for and I could be getting some of the
specifics wrong but I've gone through
one cycle of this
already you're getting Zapped for
something like 8 and a half to 10
minutes every hour on the
hour
for 10 hours a day for five days
straight so you're doing 50 sessions in
five days and it's a hell of a thing
but that is why I was undergoing this
psychiatric evaluation was to determine
what the diagnosis was such that they
could try to determine which coordinates
to use basically in placement of the
stimulation super super super super
interesting but the reason I brought
that up
is winding all the way back to kind of
where we
started I notice really my new details
and that means also every mistake every
like I could I could scan document I
don't know if you're like this but like
I can look at a document that four
lawyers have reviewed and find stuff wow
and I just have that ability I don't
know what it is it's it's definitely not
all blessing there's a lot of curse to
that but it's like I can I could scan a
document reading very quickly and be
like this Clause is off that punctuation
is off this
in minutes in a way that like a living
chat GPT yeah or a Rainman in some
respects but but that comes with a a
huge tax right because it drives other
people crazy right and you drive
yourself crazy and so I'm learning to
contend with that which is a way of
emphasizing how big a deal it is for me
to collaborate in the way that I'm
describing yeah I will say also that the
objective for the creative offsite for
me
was to try to create a flywheel of
collaborative potential and I'll explain
what that means in other words I wanted
to create enough imagery enough artwork
also
enough Scaffolding in terms of World
building so the mythologies the beliefs
the alliances the conflicts the
geography such that I could take all of
that and give it as a world Bible of
sorts to a writer who's never had any
exposure to the realm of varata right
the legend of cockpunch
and they would be equipped to write a
short story or a module or an adventure
for d and d a campaign who knows or a
comic book and have it align with my
Creative Vision for that entire fantasy
world which was a a cool challenge I
think you require I think it requires a
little more time those types of creative
pushes are often two to 3 weeks 3 weeks
seems to be the sweet spot but that's a
huge ask of my time and of everyone's
time and I wanted to make sure that I
felt comfortable in a shorter format
first